i'm gonna start with a few different
questions to actually try to mix this up
a little bit
uh i've been asking this of everybody uh
what tv
series would you love to guest direct
oh my god that's so hard let me think oh
okay my brain has to now engage
um what tv series well you know what
i've become obsessed and i'm just
getting to the very end of season five
of a french
show called the bureau have you come
across that i've not seen it yet
oh it's great if you like a spy show and
it goes they go
all over middle east russia and
it's brilliantly done you know mateo
kasowitz who did um
uh what's that great french movie the
black and white
uh uh you'll know it like from 20
years ago oh yeah it's great it's a
great show all right
and i would love to and i noticed that
actually in the la in this last season i
don't know this is the very last there's
the one that's available
um uh um the director of
a prophet jack odriard
directs who's one of the great directors
working in europe at the moment he
direct he
he directs a couple of the last episodes
and
um he does it he's a seek into my movie
um he's the guy who discovered tahar
rahim and put him in a prophet
and uh that's how i saw tahar first in
about 2008 and i put him in his first
english language movie
the eagle with channing tatum in 2009
and we remained friends ever since when
i thought about doing this movie
the very first person i thought i got on
the phone to was tahar
said in the script he said yes and then
we waited for two years to get the money
i actually uh i you won't remember this
i actually spoke to you for the eagle
back
ten years ago and i listen i loved a
prophet
and when i spoke to tahar guess who made
him talk about the prophet
ah you're the only one of any
sophistication in this living
i mean that that's a movie that uh you
know for anyway i could spend the whole
interview talking about a profit but
that's not why we're here
right um this is what's interesting is
i think that that it films like this
first of all congrats on this movie you
did such a great job with it
and it's one of these movies that i
think everyone should see
um but i would you just mentioned it it
took a little while to get the financing
this is not a story that i would imagine
people are like clamoring to go make
so talk a little bit about even though
with your track record
uh and the films you've delivered that
it must have been a struggle
it was it was difficult to finance uh i
won't lie
um it's obviously a hard time for indie
movies it's harder for all movies right
now it's a hard time
even before for indie movies and um
you know luckily uh project attracted an
amazing cast you know as a kind of dream
cast of people
and that's the reason we got to make it
but everyone made it for
basically nothing and we all did it
because we thought it was an incredible
story
and we particularly wanted to tell
muhammadu's story because
that was what made me want to do it i
spoke to him right at the beginning of
the process i read the book
i was like i don't know how do i make a
movie out of this another film about the
war on terror
then i spoke to him and he was so
surprising he wasn't
i expect him to be bitter broken angry
and he's the opposite of that
he's a man who's fully alive who
can talk seriously about what happened
to him there but without
bitterness and um who's trying
consciously to forgive he's made this
real decision i don't want to be
swallowed up by hatred and
resentment and revenge i want to move on
from that and it's a hard thing for him
it's every day he
says you know i have to you know go yeah
okay don't think about that
think it this way and but the other
thing about him is that he's a
you know huge pop culture fanatic he
could probably you know take you on at
your own game
he um particularly in the period 2004 to
2015 when he's locked up in a cell
and one time he's listening to all the
music that his guards are like 20 year
old kids from arkansas
are listening to um he's listening to
um uh you know terrible country music
i think it's terrible country music and
he and he can sing all these
all these terrible country songs he's
watching every movie
um falling in love with the big lebowski
watching 86 times
um which is why of course we've got that
song from dylan at the end of the movie
there's a sort of homage to that um so
he's just unexpected
and a beautiful person and that's what
made me want to do it i thought i would
tell the story of this man and in a way
the humanizing of this
character who you know would lump him in
as you know he's a muslim terrorist
suspect
enough actually to take that story and
to take that individual and humanize him
fully so that
hopefully the audience really care about
him by the end of it
that was the goal and that's why
everyone else that's why the other
actors were attracted to as well
they loved the idea of that yeah well
mission accomplished
um one of the things that people might
not realize or not might not think about
is the fact that jodie foster is very
selective
with the roles she is willing to do and
she has only made a few movies in the
last 10 years
so what was it like sort of courting her
to be in this because landing her is a
really big deal
oh yeah i mean look she's she's one of
my old-timers
you know she's i'm you know she is a
legend as a veritable legend
she's been you know making classic
movies when she's 11
10 years old or whatever through till
now and
we sent it to her pretty certain that
she would say no we'd move on to you
know second choice
uh because she doesn't do anything and i
phoned up her agent who
who was really a new agent for her she
had
her old agent she's had since she was a
kid and finally retired
the new agent who i knew slightly i
phoned up and i said i've got this thing
for jody and said i have no idea what
she's looking for
i don't know you know i should take it i
don't know send it to her send it to me
send it off three days later jody um
emails and says this is really
interesting let's talk so i flew to la
we sat down we talked for hours and
hours about all sorts of stuff
um and she told me that she told me that
her mom had recently passed away and her
mom
uh was a huge influence in her career
her mom was her
manager for most of her career and um
she told me that her mom had briefly
converted to islam in the 70s and had
taken her to to the mosque a little bit
and so she was fascinated by the islamic
element of this as well and that was one
of the reasons
but i think more than anything else
she's looked at and go i know how to do
this
and she it was interesting because the
process of working on the script we
worked together on her character quite a
bit
and it was all about taking stuff out i
don't need this backstory
i don't need this dialogue people are
going to know who i am and this is about
a professional woman who's given up
everything in her life just to
concentrate on her work
the discipline of that as an actor to
sort of go this is what i need
it was really remarkable to work with
and she was very you know she was she
she was very good on on scenes like the
scene at the end with muhammadu
where um she goes to see
him after she's read what he's been
through and
there was there was a three or four line
exchange between the two of them at the
top of that scene
and which i thought was really beautiful
and she said we were
reading through it with muhammad and she
said you're going to need that and i
said no i'm not taking that out i love
that no
don't need it take it out and so i was
the only time we had a really argument
and then of course i get into the
cutting room i've got this thing i go oh
[ __ ]
you don't need those lines do you you
took them out straight away first thing
and she was totally right so you know
that just shows hey she's so astute
well the other thing is jody's a very
talented director and so
what is it like working with an actor
who's also a very talented director
and did you ever sort of get the feeling
that maybe on one
scene or whatever she was so close to
just saying something
like i would do it this way well you
know what
that of course was going in the back of
my mind before we started i thought oh
my god you know she's such a great
director
and uh she's so experienced in front of
the camera behind the camera
but i think i don't know whether it's
because she can compartmentalize her
life or whether she's just very
disciplined but she
was probably the single most responsive
actor i've ever worked with and this is
that she
she did not say unnecessary things about
you know
maybe i could do this i could wear a hat
you know
she was you know she was there to serve
the story
and um if you gave her a note
she would nod and execute it
and i was you know amazed and
and i think that you know she's switched
she i think she's just compartmentalized
i'm now an actor
i'm now here to serve the director and
serve the script
and you know the other side of me i'll
talk about it tonight
but i'm not going to talk about it now
so yeah that was real that was a real
pleasure
and uh the fun thing is i worked i
worked with i worked with ben affleck on
a movie a
while ago and he obviously is a great
director
and it was very similar actually you
know very had a similar
kind of aspect of um you know
i'm actually quite glad to switch off
the director side of me and i'm just now
at your disposal do with me what you
will so i don't
think that they know how much work uh uh
what it is to be a director and how much
is going on and
maybe they enjoy just shutting that off
i think that's also true yeah i think
that's also true that they understand
you know you've got to make your day
you've got 16 setups to do
you know you cannot spend two hours and
i think i think that is very true
actually that
actors who have not directed um
sometimes can be completely oblivious to
all of that and all the other things
that you were
you know you were thinking about oh my
god that person's wig tomorrow is not
gonna be a problem
will that old car start and how are we
gonna do that shot if we don't have the
crane and all those things that are
going around your head
any one time uh they're quite glad to
let go of all of that
obviously the stuff with dahar there's
so much that he
has to deliver in this performance and
there's so much physically that he has
to
do um can you sort of talk about what it
was like on set directing him
and trying because you have the history
with documentary films
um in all your documentaries and i know
you're always going for the realism of
the moment
sort of talk about you know crafting
these scenes
well with tahar
um it's such a complex character it's
such a
you know here's to such a tiny little
needle
and he has to be one time both
suspicious threatening a little bit
potentially dangerous you want to not
really know who he is but at the same
time
you want to begin to be charmed by him
and progressively more charmed by him
and
kind of fall in love with him by the end
of the movie um
and so that's a you know it's really
hard to
get to to calibrate that and
so we would do a lot of different takes
just
try a little bit more this week way and
he very quickly became obvious that
he loved to just play with the scenes
and explore
and you know we would have talked about
in advance a little bit of rehearsal
whatever but actually
he got on front of the camera he would
um
try it ten different ways until he found
ah
there there's a bit of this a bit of
that those ingredients the spices that
go into this scene
and you know that's a marvelous way to
work because it's not
you know when you're actually doing it
rather than like dictating
no this is how you say this line this is
you know when you actually you it's a
collaboration between you and the actor
where you're trying to take you're
discussing it like that
emotion there the way you did that lot
you know and then you you can shape the
whole piece like that in the moment
and i think jody and shayleen who are
very different kind of actors you know
they're
very much in the more in the hollywood
mold you know
they they come very prepared they've
thought about their intention in the
scene in that moment in that line and
they
do it like that they were really stunned
by him i think
and loved you know they said to me after
the first day god that's like
you know having your own private one-man
theater show he's like doing all these
different things in front of you and
they find it incredibly entertaining
to watch him and um
so so and he's also alan cookler who's
the
who's the dp on this was an old friend
of mine and
he and i just loved shooting dahar
because he's very light aware he knows
where
there's a really interesting light he'd
always find an interesting shadow or the
interesting highlight or whatever
i think subconsciously i don't think
he's thinking about that stuff but he's
very just
he thinks like a filmmaker rather than
like a so he's like a theater act in one
way but he's a very film friendly actor
in another way so you know the first
scene we shot with him because jody got
really ill
over the christmas break that we had and
she couldn't come back
and and so we had to bring a lot of
stuff forward to do other things to you
know rearrange the schedule
and the very first day that shahar had
was his end
speech that he has to give at the end of
the film he's been through everything
and i was like oh good oh disaster
and dahar was like playing it very cool
playing very cool but i knew he must be
this like
cursing me in the situation and he
turned up
and he said looking into the lens at the
end of the camera
speaking right into the camera and he
delivers this speech the first time
so powerfully so movingly and alvin and
i look at each other and like
oh my god he is going to be brilliant
and as we knew right from that very
first
take that he totally had you know he
immersed himself into this person
so deeply and uh yeah from there on it
you know it got better and better and he
he he he
the funny thing about is i've worked
with actors who are you know very
immersive before
and kind of you know methody and that
could be really
a nightmare for a director as well
because they never switch off
and um you know they're totally
humorless about everything
but tahar's like you know then he's like
out chatting with everybody hugging the
makeup people
having one of his three packets of
cigarettes a day his 10th espresso
being charming french i mean it's
amazing amazing
that uh that's fantastic um
uh i have so many questions and i'm
running out of time so i'm trying to
figure out what i want to actually bring
up with you
um i guess i want to talk a little bit
about the editing because
this is something as you mentioned that
you shot certain scenes a number of
different ways talk a little bit about
the challenge of
crafting everything in the editing room
and also i'm always obsessed with like
if a director had a much longer cut
uh before uh finalizing yeah a longer
car
my editor got back from shooting in
mauritanian south africa to my editor
justine who i've worked with for
23 years now um and
she was like pale and i said what's
wrong with you
well the you know the the assembly is
three hours and 15 minutes
i don't know how we're gonna get this
down and
uh you know i was like well it's better
to be too long or too short i suppose
and uh we we you know we had we got it
down to two and a half hours it was a
really nice cut at two and a half hours
but it's obviously still too long and
from there it was painful taking things
out
and so you know the movie is still just
over two hours
um and uh you know that was already
already
already already long so yeah there is a
longer there's a long cup i mean i think
what
what what exists what the challenge with
the editing
was that this is you know it's an
incredibly complex structure by far the
most complex structure i've ever
tried in a film because you've got three
different time periods
and you've got three different character
main characters who you're following
each individually at different times
so you know that's 3d chess right there
you know it's really
really complex and so a lot of our time
was spent you know obviously
nuancing individual scenes but then a
lot of times spent
moving these bits around a little bit
you know can you put that
there or we need we feel like need a
little more of jody or we need it you
know
this that and that's also why a lot of
decisions were made when we were
shooting it about different styles of
shooting different use of color
and different aspect ratios in order to
have a psychological effect but also to
differentiate
between different periods of the
audience you know hopefully not noticing
those things consciously but they're
they're not lost they know i'm here i'm
there i mean in that time
and and i think that's one of the things
i i think justine did an incredible job
because
i haven't heard anybody you know many
criticisms but i've never heard anyone
say i was confused which is amazing can
you consider all of that
all of that material believe me i
i could talk a whole bunch about the
aspect ratio changes
but i i am curious because this this
story has
so much in it um normally uh i'm like
okay i don't need to see
the deleted scenes or whatever but is
the cut that you had at two and a half
hours something that's like finished
where at some point you might release an
extended cut or
something you know how it goes these
days i mean it's sort of like you know
if this movie makes any money which is
hard when the
theaters are closed um then they might
spend a little more money on
on that back end and i would love to do
that because i think it is i think it is
interesting and because it's not a movie
with
a ton of special effects uh because it's
mostly in camera
um it's not that expensive to do a you
know a
a cheap kind of video finish on
something so yeah we
we we i would love i would love to do
that
and i think um you know because it is is
because so many characters are in this
um i think in some ways it can benefit
from
it can benefit from that because you get
a little more time with everybody
there's so much to this story
and i i do think that you guys did an
amazing job with the edit keeping
everything going
because it's over different periods and
i think the aspect ratios really helped
and
the different you know color and
filmmaking yeah
yeah no i i i agree um on that note i'm
gonna stop and just say
congrats and uh we did not talk about
iguanas but next time
oh yeah i love the iguana scene one of
my favorite scenes
okay don't that really nice really nice
to chat and
thanks for asking interesting questions
for the end of my day